べっチェンジャー片頭痛わかるよ僕は雨が降る日の前日に絶対に頭痛がくるタイプなん
で当日は大丈夫なんですけども前日がきついです皆さんヘビー m 霞してます
でしょうか
もうなんか動画では歩ぐらい使われると思うんですけどもうあの辺ご縁って書かれる
くらいなんですけどヘリウムガス数と声が高くなるんです1回やってみますね
[音楽]
はーはっはあああああああああを撮りました
で感じに一瞬高くなるんですけどすぐ戻っちゃうんですよおもろ
ないん
[音楽]
ああっはぁ
あぁこんな感じで声かわいいですねアーっても高い高い高いほどダーイまでなら今じゃ
ないでもだいぶ超えたし続けるとちょっとずつ戻ってくるんじゃあ最終的にはアウト
もうちょっと高くだったなああああああああっもうましたーーー
パンッ
高いなぁあれもう度なっちゃったあっはい
戻りましたん
素の声を忘れたっていうわけで今日の動画はヘリウム出すたくさん吸いすぎると
声もどんどんなくなるドッキリイェーイグッズのファンにアホがいるんですね
今日は2人呼ぶんですけどもたくさんは自重強いんで心配する係として仕掛け人です
わかりました俺と思うんすよこういったけどさすがにねえからなんかこういうもどん
だけだっても思わせべ空気になるとアホみたいな積んで入っても大丈夫ですか
ぶーぶーっ
本当にマジで戻らなくなったって言ってすげー
は2きます付2 way 読まないじゃん
すっげー俺は衣装この方になったよって設定でお2人を驚かせたいと思います
ならばいっ宜しくお願いしますしくお願いします
はフィリ有無がその日続けるとどんどんに声が怠くなるのかって言う
わかりましたん
やりましょう吉江マックへ
これはこの声で俺ますねちょっとこれが俺がおいしいっ
タルカス500ないだろうまた残念な本説明してないですえっとですねヘリウムガス
スイーツ付けるとめっちゃ覚えどこまで高くなるのかって言う
気迫でございますねちょっと手伝ったおじさんにこうどんどん俺に
サービスレースですねああああ
いきますいますね素の声をいただくと愛ですよこれがちょっと着なってきますから
[音楽]
ていません
はいよこのワードここで飛んでる
黒子さん占いハーフ
[音楽]
水へすげー
ワーワーやってて夢中度で鞘バイアンプ4 a
主やー delno
うんっ
しゅわー
[笑い]
はーい
[音楽]
ああああああ
ん
わー
[音楽]
しっ
ん
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
[音楽]
ん
さぶらふええええええ
voodoo ん
[音楽]
もないようなんだ
ブーバーし
パッ葉を番くらいあったけど
20秒とかで子です時間稼働でない
どんな本とぴ12とか中芸とブードゥ
なんか結構やっ
すごく4沿いはっはっは
やばいでしょどっ
ヴィッカ違ってガッツペッ
薄1回振って入ってパワー
はぁっはぁっはぁっ体を出すんがぁああああああっ派ワインとそのが出荷地が違ってる
to あるべきてこれやばいん
一生これでってうさんおはようなんでこんな
な人いないですよねそう時間
どんなに行ってる間ないと思ってたんだけど
結構いやご活用はガチでガチなら
が3がうまくない今後の ios んだからねっ
おっしゃるん
新しいはずですよ
ブーバー殺すぞ
ん
ねえじゃん結構強いな
甘いしゃべればしゃべるほど面白い
祖父江リム画素はめっちゃ濃度が高いから
あるいは経済が危ない恐竜動機だっただけじゃねーぞ本当精霊
増えると危険だけどこれの
その身のところない問題は声
これぞ
だと結構経ってる酔っ払いそんないい子じゃなかったです
いいするん
ん
んあっあああああああっても大丈夫です
大丈夫コンビは断りますね姉直轄地白鳥たちや
アーサーこれはどんなやっぱこの半分位は勝ったねそうね
いやあるねこれだけならふざけ
はいがスゴこれはやだなん
随分前だってたんだよっ
一緒3キミっての声優が仕事ができます
そっかーなんだよいいんだろう何かと思う
呼吸器まーひーぽんん
そっちらなぁいやーこれ戦略
正体がダル気づいてる方にからこの多い
希ガス月戦隊綺麗ですございまし
ん
水を入れ足がつかないといけばシャンプー
[音楽]
言わ超日曜日じゃんあおそろしては骨けどねぇ
わざわざは良いに贈ったんですけどって
ゲームのスってからこれもホンダれちゃってっ
振り向かってもそういったいっしょに本部な逆1リーグはスってますね
読み上げ止めます
思っています
これはそういう派
pr
ああああああ
ホイッ
ん
w
はい以上です
[音楽]
padi
手順ガスを大量に吸ったら声が戻っなくなるポッキーでした
俺なんかに貼っちゃったってたい店じゃないんですけど2ので月なんだけど
切れ街の瞬間だけ自分でも声が増えますねさあつなげて